[موسيقى]
في احدى معارك نابوليون بونابارت ضد
النمسه حظي الامبراطور الفرنسي بمعلومات
استخباراتيه مهمه مكنته من كسب المعركه
قدمها له ضابط نمساوي خان شعبه وبلاده
ولما جاءه يتقاضى المكافاه امسك نابوليون
بسره من الذهب ورماها على الارض فقال
النمساوي معاتبا على الارض ترمي مكافاتي
بدل التقدم لمصافحته وما كنت منتصرا لولا
مساعدتي اجابه بونابارت عا لي حالك فيا
شهم ومؤلف بيتين شعر جايه تاكل راسي فيهم
هذا الذهب ثمن ما قدمته لنا اما يدي فبدون
لا تصافح رجلا يخون شعبه وبلاده الى العوي
صحف عربيه روسيا تمنع الاسد من زياره حلب
والقاء خطاب
الانتصار الباجي قائد السبسي يعتقد ان
السنه الحاليه هي عام
2011 شبان بحرينيون يطهرون رمزيا مكان
اقامه طقوس صهيونيه في
المنامه امريكا بريطانيا تركيا ايران حماس
حزب الله وداعش فق على تهريب مرسي ورانيا
تكشفهم في اليمن انشقاق حمير عن الحوثيين
بعد اعتقالهم من قبل الجيش
[موسيقى]
والمقاومه مرحبا ماذا يجري في سوريا بوتين
واردوغان اتفقا على وقف النار هكذا تبلغت
ايران وبشار بعد كل هذا الحشد الشيعي من
افغانستان الى لبنان ياتي رجب ليخلط شعبان
برمضان ويتنازل لروسيا بعدما شعر بغدر
الامريكان ليحصل الحرب على داعش وكردستان
بعد ان كانت على الثوره
والانسان هيدا هو ملف المريضه شام خلينا
نشوف كيف بدنا نعالج مرض السرطان اللي
انتشر بجسم دكتور الكساندر شو رايك انا
بشوف ضروره استئصال الاورام الحره قبل ما
تنتشر وتنتقل الادوى ل باقي الجسم
وللجيران
دكتور علم دار شو بتقول يجيب ودشا في
قنايه فاكه وقد اتفقنا انا والدكتور
الكسندر على وضع هتا لتجميد جميع هجمات
فتاكه بالجسد جميل جميل دكتور
نيراني انا ارى
تقسيمه جسد شام الى عده اقسام كل واحد منا
يقوم بمعالجه قسمه على طريقته اقترح عليك
الكيماوي صدقني هذا الحل
الانسب المثل بيقول اسال مجرب ولا تسال
حكيم انا مجرب
وحكيم مين حكي حدا قال شيء شباب انا سمعت
حدا قال شيء انا انا دكتور نظام كنت عم
ققول انت مين طلب رايك
اساسا صوتك ما بدي اسمعه منيح اللي حكيت
لنعرف انك موجود
خلص انتهت طالما الدكتور الكساندر
والدكتور عالم دار اجتمعوا ووضعوا خطه
للعلاج ما عاد في لزوم لب العراق انتم
خليكم بصم
الطوارئ الرمد افضل من العمه والغريق
يتعلق بقشه هكذا عبر معظم العرب الذين
قابلناهم في اسواق الدوحه عن تاييده اتفاق
وقف النار في سوريا رغم تعرضه لعشرات
الخروق فيما انقسم رافضو وقف النار الى
فريقين مثل ما بقول الغريق يتعلق بقشه
يعني مش معقول يا عم السلام وفي جماعات
ارهابيه الاسد لازم يخرج لازم ينزل لما
يوصلوا لحل كيف
يقسموا الغنائم راح تخلص وقف اطلاق النار
يتم لو النظام راح في مثل بقول اللي بياكل
العصي غير يل عى يعني انت ما بدك يوقف
النار الا للنظام يخرج مرق خمس سنين على
هذا الكلام احنا ين هون بدنا نترك
السوريين مع القصف قصف الطيران ومع
المدافع ومع هول البراميل اس خمس سنين
اضافيه لان هم مشوا في في طريق ولازم
يكملوه هذا خلاف بين دوله وشعب واحنا ما
قنا فيه بس المهم يكون في وقف اطلاق نار
بغض النظر انا لا مع الحكومه ولا مع
المعارضه وان شاء الله يكون في تصالح من
بين الدول العربيه كلها شو افضل طريقه
لتتوقف الحرب بسوريا افضل
طريقه حل السلام حل السلام شو افضل طريقه
ليحل السلام الحرب تنتهي والش حلوه منك
انا اسمي ارش يعني معناته اتفاق يعني حب
الاتفاق ما حب المشاكل اريد قلبا طيبا لا
حشو مقيه اريد يوما مشمسا فلحظه
انتصار مجنونه
نميه كشفت صحيفه العرب الصادره في لندن
نقلا عن مصادر عربيه وثقه الصله بالقياده
الروسيه ان موسكو منعت الرئيس السوري بشار
الاسد من زياره حلب في عيدي الميلاد وراس
السنه والقاء خطاب الانتصار في المدينه
اضافت الصحيفه ان الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين كان قد حصل من الاسد بعيد التدخل
العسكري الروسي المباشر على التزامات
واضحه تقضي باتباع الاسد ما تمليه عليه
موسكو بشكل حرفي بحسب الصحيفه في هذا
الوقت كان وزير الخارجيه السوري وليد
المعلم ينظم ابياتا تلفزيونيه في السياده
والاستقلال نحن لا نسام على سيادتنا
الوطنيه وزير الخارجيه التركي تحدث عن انه
لا يمكن قبول وجود الرئيس الاسد في السلطه
في سوريا ما ردكم على مثل هذا الكلام هل
يستحق هذا الكلام رد يوجد طرفه في المجتمع
الدولي كل من طالب برحيل الرئيس الاسد رحل
وبقي الاسد نعم ربما هذا مصير اوغلو كمان
استاذ وليد طبعا اوغل سيذهب هناك انتخابات
بتشيله وبتشيل اللي اكبر منه بس انت الله
يخليك بصحتك شو بده يشيلك
خيو المعلم سئل عن الوجود الاجنبي المسلح
لصالح النظام في سوريا حزب الله موجود في
سوريا بطلب رسمي من الحكومه الشرعيه
السوريه له لكي ي اخي العزيز بالنسبه لحلب
مالها شغله بشغلات القانون ه امور عقائديه
هذول نواصب العصر ولذلك هذا ما يستوجب ان
ناخذ امر من رئيس الوزراء وانما ها امور
عقائديه احنا نعتقد بهم هذول نواصب العصر
النظام السوري لا يزال مصرا على نظريه
اختفاء اوروبا فبعد خمس سنوات على التصريح
الشهير لوليد المعلم الرئيس الاسد يجدد
فكره زوال اوروبا عن الخريطه السياسيه ان
جزءا من التفاؤل يتعلق بقيام علاقات افضل
بين الولايات المتحده وروسيا وليس بين
الغرب وروسيا لان اوروبا ليست موجوده على
الخريطه السياسيه سننسى ان اوروبا على
الخارطه الاعلمي المصري سعيد حساسين علق
على تسامح الرئاسه الروسيه بعد طرد واشنطن
الدبلوماسيين الروس فراى ان فلاديمير
بوتين ليس قويا الا على النساء نساء حلب
35 د دبلوماسي روسي اوباما طردهم و وبوتين
بقى احنا قلنا بقى بوتين هيخش بقى ويكسر
الدنيا وازاي رجالتي وبتاع انما الحقيقه
بوتن ده شاطر على نساء حلب واطفال حلب فقط
مقاتل سابق مع حزب الله في سوريا مفصول من
الحزب لاسباب مسلكيا كما اشيع عاد الى
لبنان فقتل الاسبوع الماضي على يد الشرطه
اثناء قيامه مع شريك له بعمليه سطو مسلح
على مصرف في ضاحيه بيروت
الجنوبيه ليس دفاعا عن القتيل لكنه سارق
سمول وفي لبنان يوجد سارقون لارج واكس اكس
لارج هذا ما يقوله سياسيون علنا واليوتيوب
متخم بالفيديوهات يتبادلون التهم بسرقه
المليارات ثم يتصالحون ويتقاسمون مراكز
الدوله ولا احد منهم يخضع للمحاسبه غيض من
فيض في هذا العرض بتجيب بتجيب المحضر
وبتقرا ضض بحالك وض
[تصفيق]
برسك حرام
الكهربا استجوبت الشرطه الاسرائيليه على
مدى ثلاث ساعات رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو وذلك في شبهه تلقيه هدايا من رجال
اعمال اسرائيليين واجال
خلافا
للقانون لا اعرف نفرح لان المجرم نتنياهو
يترشح ام نحزن على واقعنا العربي حيث
الكبار محصنون دائما حتى ولو كانوا شراشيح
ويعون ثم هل من الممكن ان يكون استجواب
نتنياهو اصلا عملا لتجميل وجه اسرائيل
القبيح في المنطقه فونديشن لمكافحه الفساد
احمر شفاه لادعاء الشفافيه الى باقي
المستحضرات
[موسيقى]
انهى الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
التوتر مع الحكومه العراقيه وذلك باتصاله
برئيسها حيدر العبادي حيث اكد له ان انقره
تتطلع الى نصر عراقي قريب جدا في الموصل
وتطرق المسؤولان الى الزياره القريبه
لرئيس الوزراء بن علي يلدرم لدمشق
لبغداد
ربما زياره دمشق تتم في الحلقه المقبله
وقال اردوغان للعبادي انت لست ندي ولست
بمستواي والزم حدك لا يا جماعه هذا الكلام
سابق هذا في
اكتوبر هو يوجه الشتائم الى شخصي اصلا انت
لست من مستواي ولا من قيمتي ولست من يمكن
ان اوجه له حديثي صراخك في العراق لا
يهمنا نحن نفعل ما هو صحيح بالنسبه لنا من
هذا انه رئيس وزراء العراق يا هذا قبل كل
شيء يعرف حدودك في العراق تنتشر كل يوم
فيديوهات لمواطنين من جمهور الاحزاب
الحاكمه بداوا يتذمرون من استفحال الازمات
المعيشيه ومن اتساع الهوه بين رموز وكوادر
الاحزاب الحاكمه من جهه وجمهورها الكادح
من جهه اخرى هذا حال الشعب العراقي وخصه
الحكم الشيعي من الله يطيع حقكم يا رضون
انتم كل من ذب العمامه على راسه وتمون
الشيعه ترضون هاي مع احترامات الزينين شوف
هاي م هاي منطقه شيعيه وشعبيه كبيره وداوم
بها الطلاب الكليه والموظفين وكل احنا
مضحين للدوله عرفت شلون كلبيت ب ثلا شهداء
اربع شهداء كلها بالحشد الشعبي احنا ناس
فقره جعانين تعبانين يعني هذا الشارع انضح
ثم شهداء يا مسؤول تنضح الشهداء اكو مسؤول
وين
المسؤولين
الانتخابات طيب لماذا كرر المواطنون
انتخاب هؤلاء المسؤولين طالما انهم
يتهمونهم
بالفساد انها حكمه المشايخ وما ظلمناهم
ولكن هم كانوا انفسهم يظلمون ك من نعطيها
اعطيها العزه الدور يرجعنا على صدورنا
الحكم الاموي كم عمي طلعوا بس اختار لك
واحد شريف اختار الخوش ادمي اختار النزيه
بس لا تقوللي ما اطلع وما انتخب عمي عيب
لان هذه حرب بينه وبين عندنا بث مباشر بس
انتم عرفوا اللي بين وبين اطلعوا نصره
للمذهب اطلع انتخب اي كان على قاطات
الحكومه وعلى طلايب الحكومه وعلى مشاكلها
ال يوميه احنا مشتم بهم بس مع ذلك خلف
الله عليهم خليها اسمها تنادي باشه ان علي
ولي الله حتى لو كذب حتى المشايخ ندموا
وهذا صلاح الطفيلي نفسه عاد لاحقا ليتر
على ايام الرئيس صدام حسين خليتونا نحين
ترى على ذاك الرجال قمنا نحين ايش قد كنا
احنا شبعانين مغمه وسجون وترهيب وقتل بس
عمي خلي يرجع بطلنا خي يرجع عما يمكن انتو
نصكم هسه تنتخبون صدام درج عم
[موسيقى]
بطلنا الرئيس التونسي الباجي قايد السبسي
يسبق زمنه بخمس سنوات على الاقل ففيما
انتظر العالم الاسبوع الماضي سنه
2017 كان وحده يقف في العام 2021 هذايا بع
القرن الماضي احنا ت في 2000 يعني
21 في 2 يعني
21 في المنام ولتبقى البحرين طاهره قام
شباب بحرينيون بعمليه تطهير رمزي لمكان
زياره الوفد اليهودي الداعم لاسرائيل
مؤخرا المملكه واقامته شعائر دينيه فيها
تخللتها اناشيد تدعو لاقامه الهيكل في
البيرو تدخل مشعوذون في عمليات ارساء
السلام العالمي وقاموا بما يعتقدون انه
تطهير لقلب دونالد ترامب وقلب فلاديمير
بوتين
[موسيقى]
اكد مراسل تلفزيوني يمني ان قطيعا من
الحمير العائده للحوثيين في الجبال تمت
السيطره عليها وقد بدات على الفور بخدمه
الجيش الوطني المقاومه الشعبيه الحمار هذا
منين نزلتم الى راس الجبل هذا نزلناه من
فوق هو كان معكم ا في او تبع كان عفاشي
يسرنا من حق العفاشي ضمن الاسر ذحين
فرمتنا على علينا اذا مشاهدينا الكرام حتى
الحمير هي كانت خاصه هذه هي كانت حمير
امداد الحوثي وكما راينا الطقوم وراينا
المكره حتى الحمير اصبحت تحت سيطره الجيش
الوطني وبدات هذه الحمير تؤدي دورها
بالشكل المطلوب انها تخدم افراد الجيش
الوطني والمقاومه
الشعبيه سن الاعلامي المصري يوسف الحسيني
هجوما بلغه غير مسبوقه على السعوديه وكتب
على تويتر تيران وصنافير مصريه وستظل
مصريه ولن نتركها حتى لو اعدنا تركيع
الدرعيه واعدنا ال رشيد
للحكم في هذا الوقت كان الحسيني يبكي على
الشاشه لان احدا لم يستطع اعاده ابراهيم
الى برنامجه بعد قرار توقيفه بامر من
السلطه عمر اديب هيا كفنه ولميس الحديدي
ستشتغل في التريكو وحياه امي انا ما بدمع
على ابراهيم طب بدمع ليه انا بدمع على حال
البلد اللي بقى وحش قوي انتم
السابقون نحن اللحق ايه التطاول ده ايه
الهدم ده وربنا كرمكم انه انتوا جيتوا في
اجواء تطلعوا على رجليكم في حريه اك اكتر
من اللي احنا فيها انا ست بقى هقعد اخيط
بعمل تريكو واشغل في البيت ما هم دول شله
واحده يا عم طظ
فينا الاعلامي تامر امين وافق الرئيس
السيسي على ان الشعب المصري نجح في
الاختبار لكنه حان وقت التخرج انه
المصريين عدوا من الاختبار الصعب ونجحوا
فيه نجاح باهر مش هو الريئس قال كده
والحقيقه ان هو على حق بس انا بقول له يا
ريس
والنبي كفايه
اختبارات يا رييس لو سمحت كفايه اختبارات
الاعلامي جابر القرموطي وفي اخر تقليعات
واكب مشروع استزراع السمك على طريقته لكن
لفتت مطالبته بوقف نظم الاشعار بالسيسي
على الطريقه القديمه لاحظنا هنلاقي الناس
اللي كانت بتطلع السمك وهو لاخره وطبعا
مسائل بقى اللي بيقول شعر واللي بيقول نسر
واللي بيقول كذا واللي بيقول عبد الفتاح
السيسي او والسم من من اول حرف من اسمك
عين واخر حرف من اسمك ح وحاجات كده وبتاع
وكلام من دهت انا بس اتمنى الناس يعني
ايه ما حدش حد بياكل من الكلام ده قوي
يعني الاعلاميه ريهام سعيد طلبت من
الخريجين انلا يوفروا فرصه عمل حتى لو
كانت بالوقوف على ابواب المراحيض العامه
وتحدثت عن اعمالها المتواضعه في فتره
شبابها قالوا لي بس احنا مش عايزين دلوقتي
في التخصص بتاعك طب يا جماعه طب لو عندكم
شغل شغلوني قال ققول لي ممكن تيجي تقف على
الحمامات
ينفع اقف على الحمامات ينفع ايوه ينفع
هتقول لك عشان بقى مذيعه ومش حاسه انا لو
قلت لك على الشغلانات اللي انا اشتغلتها
في حياتي من وانا عندي 16 سنه رحت اشتغلت
اللي هي ان انا عايز سندوتشين كبده عايز
ساندوتشين مخ كده انا واشتغلت حاج كتير
قوي ثانيه مالهاش اي علاقه
بتخصصي ناس فوق وناس تحت معادله اقرتها
سيده دعت الرئيس السيسي الى زياره منطقه
شوبرا بلباس داخلي شتوي عايزه اقول
للاستاذ الباشا بتاعنا رئيس الجمهوريه ام
استاذ عبد الفتاح السيسي انا كنت هجي لله
اه ا كنت هجي له عايزه رقابه على
شارعنا يعني في ناس تحت خالص وناس فوق
قولي لي شارع الشارع اسمه ايه شبرا شبرا
مصر اه يجي يزورها اه يا اما يبعت اللي
ورا اه ان شاء الله يا رب الناس اللي
بتتابع والمسؤولين يوصلوا له الكلام ده
عايز اروح له انا مش محتاجه حاجه ربنا
يخليك مش محتاجه حاجه انا بشكرك جدا جدا
نورتينا وعايزاه يلبس كلاسين تحت البناطيل
عشان البرد في القاهره شكوى لمواطن من سوء
الحال امام الكاميرا دفع سيده في الشارع
الى شتمه وشتم المراسله التي تجري الحوار
مش مش قادر اصرف عليها مافيش فلوس متجوزين
بقكم قد ايه بقالنا على 30 سنه خليك يا
حسين حضرتك عايزه ايه
[موسيقى]
دلوقتي حضرتك ايه ايه حضرتك يعني عايزه
ايه مشكلتك دلوقتي كويسه انتوا تبع مين
بقى جا تبص ب
وسمع حضرتك دلوقتي بتقولي رايك وانت حره
فيه وانا اطل وبقول رايي وبقول راي كل
الناسي الناس اللي مش فاهمه حاجه مع الناس
اللي مش فاهمه حاجه
معول قول مين انت
اص انتس زباله
اصبه الاعلاميه الملهمه رانيا ياسين كشفت
عن مخطط دولي لتهريب الرئيس محمد مرسي
ورفاقه في مؤامره تشترك فيها انظمه
ومنظمات كوكب الارض باستثناء اسرائيل رصد
الاجهزه الام الامنيه اجتماعا لعناصر من
المخابرات
التركيه مع البريطانيه والحرس الثوري
الايراني في مدينه خان يونس بقطع غزه من
اجل محاوله اسقاط مصر ونشر الفوضه بها من
خلال تدريب
الحرس الثوري الايراني والمخابرات التركيه
والبريطانيه لعناصر داعش وحماس والجيش
الاسلام وايضا كمان معهم حزب الله كمان من
اجل تكرار سيناريو يعني في نفس التوقيت ده
هم بيحاولوا يكرروا سيناريو احداث يناير
لتهريب مرسي من محبسه ونائب المرشد العام
وخيره الشاطر والمرشد العام السابق ليش
قطعتوها شباب لا لا اكمل مش مشكله ممدد
البرنامج دقيقه اضافيه ما بينشبع من
هالتحليل اتركوا الناس تعرف شو عم بيصير
طبعا عايزه اقول لكم كمان انه يعني كانت
امريكا بقياده الرئيس اوباما اشترطت بندا
سريا من ضمن بنود الاتفاق النووي الايراني
لما حصل بينهم اتفاق نووي ايراني كان في
قايل انه في هذا من بنود الن اللي كان
حاططها انه هو تهريب مرسي وفقا للخطه التي
يضعها بالاشتراك مع المخابرات التركيه
البريطانيه بالتعاون مع داعش وحماس وجيش
الاسلام وحزب الله
[موسيقى]
ختاما حين جاء موعد فتح مكه دخل الرسول
الاكرم بعش الاف مقاتل دخل على ناقته
والدرع على صدره والسيف في يده والنبال
على ظهره دخل منتصرا على تاريخ من ظلم
قريش له ولكل من ولاه قتلا تعذيبا وتمثيلا
نهبا سبا
وتشريدا كان اهل مكه في اللحظه الحرجه
ينتظرون دفع اثمان جبروتهم الذي زال سالهم
محمد ما ترون اني فاعل بكم فاجابه خيرا اخ
كريم وابن اخ كريم فصدر اقوى حكم في تاريخ
الحروب حكم اخضع القلوب اذهبوا فانتم
الطلقاء الى اللقاء فقام
فيهم
نبي عفو
يعرضها
مقوله هزت
الدنيا كزلزال
قوموا اذهبوا انتم
الطلقاء ليس لنا حب
انتقام
ولسنا اهل
ادغال
[موسيقى]
ا